and it is graduation season that's right
exciting time for so many students one
school in the Northeast Valley making
history this weekend it's the first
graduation class for Crystal Ray Saint
Vidor Prep School Lauren Negrete is live
at campus this morning maybe going to
take a class first period but either way
she's going to profile the first
valedictorian up there Lauren good
morning to you
good morning the morning Bell just go
off by the way so it's possible but yes
pretty soon it'll be school's out for
summer and that final Bell will will
signal the new chapter for their first
graduating class of seniors for Saint
Vidor
so our mission here is to see our kids
to and through college the school opened
in 2019. principal Erica Romero says
students spent freshman year in a
pandemic their Journey here has been
really unique and the fact that they
have come come out the other side and
they've done so well 100 of our students
have been admitted to four-year
universities they're valedictorian
Anthony cifuentes will attend Stanford
University between University
scholarships and Crystal race
scholarships and connections thankfully
I'm not paying anything and that's a
huge break my family was very low income
growing up my mom kept pushing me my dad
kept pushing me I had that support and I
made a name for myself besides being a
college prep school with AP courses
principal Romero says their 260 students
go through a corporate work study
program once a week opportunity to get
real life experience real life skills
and also sometimes even exposing the
different possible career paths even
though I've been working in all these
law oriented places I'm still getting
the critical thinking and the analytical
skills I'm going to need as I go into
medicine tuition ranges from 25 to 250
dollars a month depending on income plus
so our corporate reporters will pay a
certain amount for each student and then
that goes directly toward their tuition
so it goes to offset the cost of
attending a private Catholic School it's
an opportunity unlike any other
foreign
ER is accepting applications but for
freshmen and sophomore now there is not
a GPA requirement but you do need to
have good grades good attendance and
references from past teachers live in
North Las Vegas Lauren negretti 8 news
now all right Lauren thank you very much
congratulations to them and all the
upcoming High School seniors who are
about to graduate